Spider-Man's frame rate and into the
spider-verse reveals exactly how strong
he is let me explain most movies are
produced at 24 frames per second that
means that for every second that you see
on screen there are 24 individual images
that are playing out to make that motion
happen but you don't need that many
frames to make it fluid a lot of old
school animators actually took advantage
of this by animating at just 12 frames a
second this made things way easier back
in the day when everything had to be
hand drawn nowadays it's not so
necessary anymore what does all of this
have to do with spider-verse all of its
spider people like Peter and Gwen move
at 24 frames per second except for Miles
right after getting a spider powers
miles only moves at 12 frames per second
you can actually see it really well here
as they're escaping out into the Forest
Peter swinging is Silky Smooth while
miles is choppy at best later in the
scene as Peter's showing miles the role
to animation suddenly Smooths out to 24
frames before miles falls back to 12.
eventually as miles accepts the power
and responsibility of being Spider-Man
he moves at 24 frames per second all the
time all of it just goes to show that
there are more ways to tell a story just
like how